uh let's focus on a team that won't have
to worry about drafting high
this year the los angeles rams and
one thing i've been advocating for the
rams for the past few weeks get away
from this three-headed monster get away
from a two-headed monster
develop and rely on one guy
at the running back position cam akers
he did
that last night sean mcvay did and cam
akers had a huge night let's hear from
the rookie on
uh the big evening that he had against
the patriots
just going out and trusting trusting our
offensive line trusting the play calling
in the scheme that we've been practicing
over the past couple of days the
offensive line was
the reason the run game was so
successful tonight in my opinion
those guys got a great push every time
we ran the ball and
it showed you know the run game was very
successful tonight
and that we want to keep stacking blocks
offensive line getting it done without
andrew whitworth who's expected back at
some point the rams are peaking at the
right time and you know they've shown us
flashes this year and there have been
moments where we think wow they're
pretty damn good and then they
they lose a game like to the 49ers two
different occasions where you say what
do they really have going on here but
they've they've built some momentum now
with a big week
beating the cardinals on sunday and then
turning around on thursday night and
really
manhandling the new england patriots and
now with three games left here they're
they're their favorite to win the
division the question is can they maybe
get lucky here
if they keep doing what they're doing
win their last three get to 12 and four
does that get them in striking distance
for one of the top two spots in the nfc
not that the second seed means anything
this year because you don't get to buy
anymore but the higher you are on the
playoff tree
uh in theory the better you po the
better positioned you are to try to make
a run at the super bowl
so my cam acres was inactive twice
earlier in the season
and so he's been active for 11 games so
far this year
in eight of those 11 games he's had 10
carries or less
in the last two weeks they've started to
use him as their primo guy
21 and 29 carries but what i thought was
really interesting
watching him last night i just started
saying to myself i don't think i have
seen
a running back with the with this close
to a le'veon bell
style of running the ball as i've seen
with cam acres
the thing that made le'veon bell so
interesting
as a running back is the fact that he
was almost like a
thoughtful running back he'd get close
to the line of scrimmage
he'd see where it was bang he'd wait a
split second
then he would hit the hole and you know
be the the one cut runner going up field
okay but last night what i
saw with uh you know with cam akers was
almost exactly the same thing
he's a patient runner he's a decisive
runner between the tackles when he has
to be
but he's a patient runner when he goes
outside
and i think especially when you've got
guys who can clear it out
like joe noteboom nobody knew who he was
basically
until last night and now his job on the
left side of that line i thought last
night
really helped the rams uh dominate uh
new england which
you very rarely see and especially you
don't have whitworth
and and you play that well in the run
game that's a tremendous job
by by the rams the rams are carrying a
major scar from the todd gurley
experience they gave him the big
contract
it it didn't work out after that because
of his knee problem dating back to
georgia
and they wanted to be more like the
49ers this year with multiple
running backs being relied upon on a
regular basis
they have settled back into developing
that one guy and letting that one guy
carry the load with daryl henderson
being the backup and malcolm brown being
the
thanks for participating option but
there are parallels of the 49ers that
were noticed last night peter and it
makes me wonder
how this rams offense is going to look
as we get closer and closer to the
playoffs and into january
games still not completely resolved
still a window for the patriots to make
something happen
and you get a third in medium and you
run the ball
you get a couple of those instances
where it looks like an obvious pass
situation
and sean mcvay takes the ball out of his
supposed franchise quarterback's hand
that reminds me a lot of after kyle
shannon got freaked out by jimmy
garoppolo
early in the second half of the
divisional playoff win over the vikings
and
shifted to heavy run and then the
entirety of the nfc championship game
when jimmy garoppolo had a bob griezy
stat line with like eight passes for the
entire game
i i i can't help but wonder whether or
not that's what we're going to see
from the rams if if this run game's
working
there's no reason to trust anything to
jared goff
totally agree i mean last night cam
akers
you know uh 29 rushes jared goff
25 passes and that's not an accident
because i think that any coach any coach
no matter how much he wants to fill the
air with footballs and sean mcvay
certainly does
is going to play a game exactly the way
that sean mcvay played it last night
when and if he's got a guy who's rushing
it for six yards every time
he touches the ball on average and the
one other thing i think about mcvay
i think people over the last three or
four years have basically
said about mcveigh you know he just all
he wants to do is throw the ball
look at him working with the
quarterbacks all the time that's all he
wants to do
look i i mean there's no question he's
excited about his passing game and
wants to make the passing game work but
the bottom line is mike
you know he's like every smart coach
who has ever coached when your running
game is working
it's the safest way to move the ball
don't put the ball in the air as much
and that's exactly what he did now last
week uh
you know last week his quarterback threw
it 47 times
and last night his quarterback threw at
25. i don't expect
jared goff to throw it 25 times a lot
but i think sean mcvay also doesn't want
to throw it
47 times he's just like the steelers
randy feigner right now
knows that the last two weeks he's
thrown at 104 times
roethlisberger has and he says i do not
want to do that so i think you're going
to see
uh you know the rams go back to
significantly above 25 but
as long as they have acres playing like
that they're going to take advantage of
it
yeah absolutely no reason to take the
ball out of the sure things hands if cam
akers is playing like it was last night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports